At some point we weren't linguistic
creatures at all,
right?
We separated from the common ancestors
between us and chimpanzees about 6
million years ago.
And sometime during that 6 million year
process we started to be able to imitate
ourselves first and then represent
ourselves in image and action and then
only after that to start to articulate
ourselves.
So a lot of the knowledge that we have
is grounded in our embodiment,
but also in the shaping of that
embodiment across extraordinary long
periods of time.
So like there's an implicit way of being
in your form,
in your embodied form,
but more importantly,
there's an implicit way of being that's
a consequence of the fact that we've
existed within hierarchical social
structures for far longer than we were
even sharing a common ancestor say with
great apes.
So that's for maybe hundreds of millions
of years with regards to being embedded
in a hierarchy.
So then the question is something like,
well,
for embedded in the hierarchy,
and we have been forever,
that's about 350 million years.
By the way,
is there a set of attributes that tends
reliably to move you up the hierarchy?
Because if there is,
you see being going up,
the hierarchy increases the probability
of reproductive success.
So there's actually nothing more
important to determine over the course
of 350 million years inside a hierarchy.
Then how it is that you ratchet yourself
up the hierarchy reliably,
and you could think about that in some
sense as the source of ideals here.
Here's a kind of a concrete way of
thinking about that.
You know,
if you get a hundred men together,
they're going to,
they're going to organize themselves
into a hierarchical structure.
They have to,
or they're going to stay chaotic and
fight that.
That's the other alternative.
And so,
but the way that,
that,
that the people who are going to rise to
the top,
they might rise to the top because of
their sheer physical prowess and power.
But they also might rise to the top
because they're very competent at
certain things.
And it's as if all the men are going to
get together and vote.
And maybe that would actually happen to
determine who best embodies the spirit
of the group and who should be granted
leadership.
And in an evolutionary context,
by the way,
that would also help ensure that that
person would propagate their genes into
the next generation.
And it's not a trivial effect,
especially among men.
It's a big effect because roughly
speaking,
half half of all men or are not
reproductively successful.
So there's a wicked,
there's a wicked,
uh,
calling,
let's say among men.
While you can see this among chimpanzees
as well,
they have dominance hierarchies.
Some sort of chimps rise to the top.
And you might think,
well,
that's the,
like caveman chimp who's best at
pounding out all the,
all the rivals.
But it turns out that that's not exactly
the case in France to wall has done a
very good job of detailing this with his
work on chimpanzees in particular and
he's found that the power hungry tyrant
sort of chimp can rule for a while,
but he tends to have a very unstable
kingdom and the reason for that is is
it's not very good at mutually grooming
is not good.
It's socially connecting with other
males and he isn't popular among the
females and doesn't attend to the,
to the young essentially.
And so what happens is even if he's like
the meanest,
toughest guy on the block to subordinate
chimps team up,
they make friends,
they groom each other and they have each
other's backs and in a one day he's
having an off day because he ate too
many fermented bananas the night before
and like they just tear them into pieces
and chimps are unbelievably strong and
unbelievably brutal.
They seem to have absolutely no internal
regulation whatsoever of their
aggression.
That all seems to be manifested outside
in terms of dominance,
hierarchy,
control.
And we know that because they go on
raiding parties into other chimp
territories and when they find chimps
that aren't part of their hierarchy,
they just ripped them into pieces.
And so that's a scary thing if you think
about our similarity with chimpanzees,
cause we like to think we have internal
controls over our aggression,
but it's not so bloody obvious,
I can tell you that.
Anyways,
what the wall found was that it's
actually chimps that are more,
um,
you might say humane,
although Champaign,
I dunno what the equivalent is,
let's say humane that managed to produce
hierarchies that are more stable and
actually managed to stay alive on top of
them for much longer periods of time.
And he thinks about that as the
emergence of an implicit morality,
right?
So morality that's acted out.
So then you think,
well,
there,
there are different ways of climbing up
a hierarchy.
There are worse and better ways.
The better ways allow you to live longer
in a more stable hierarchy.
And the evolutionary payoff for that is
that you leave more,
more descendants.
And so the hierarchy itself becomes a
very powerful shaping mechanism that
determines how it is that people are
going to adapt because it's the primary
method of selection.
So there's an ethic in there.
There's an ethic that emerges from the
social interactions,
but that's rapidly transformed into a
biological selection device.
And so were selected.
And that's especially true among human
beings because with chimps,
the females are indiscriminant maters,
which is to say that a female champion
heat,
we'll meet with any mail chimp.
Now the dominant males chase the
subordinate males away.
So there's still more likely to leave
offspring than the subordinates.
But it's not because of the females,
but human females are different.
Human females exert choice and quite
brutal choice.
You might put it that way.
They're very choosy.
And it's one of the things that seems to
have distinguished us from chimpanzees.
And what roughly seems to happen is that
the male dominance hierarchy elects men
to the higher say rungs of the
hierarchy.
And then the females peel from the top.
And so that means that what you can say
is that human beings are the consequence
of intense male dominance competition.
It's not necessarily dominance,
but it's competition for the upper rungs
of the hierarchy mediated by female
selection.